we're live in New York City for three
days Adam GaSe the Jets is joining us
later on in our number three but I turn
to my right right now and it is a joy to
see you here sir because I love the show
that as I say all the time that you do
with your colleagues on Good Morning
football Peter Schrager here good to see
you but you said to throw the V here
honestly I was saying to and I will say
this to start our interview what I say
to you off camera and I'll say it to you
here on this show when we launched the
NFL Network in 2003 and I was doing an
NFL total access for all those years up
to 2011 when the lockout caused me to
lose all of my hair and and so they're
always we're always thinking there has
to be at some point another show for
which the network is known or another
tent pole yeah a good morning football
is that right that's cool and I think
the fact that we're in New York and it's
on the East Coast and coaches and GM's
are looking for something to talk
football in the morning right we're
almost the wallpaper the NFL in the
morning which is a huge honor it's cool
do you hear that a lot yeah it's just
that it's on not necessarily I'm
watching but it's on in my office and
I'm like alright cool so if that's the
case we'll take it well I mean if I
didn't have an ego you know cuz I guess
you guys know I don't have an ego even
though what true what's the name of the
show where we're in we're in London do
in the London game the Eagles versus the
Jaguars Peter you were part of that
broadcast and there's Peter and good
morning football crew was there yeah you
were there Kay Adams was there when
we're going through the interview
process with the Jacksonville staff and
the players all come in they walk right
past me right story and went right up to
Peter and panel talking about they love
their show I'm like wow I mean like I'm
on the total pay no mind list it's a
cool deal though and I'll tell you we
were in the production meeting and we're
sitting with rich it's rich it's mooch
it serve and in comes Doug Marrone and
he kind of blew me off because I had
talked negatively about the Jaguars the
week and then I said give him the hug in
the whole thing well he was in a
miserable mood it wasn't a good using
absolute miserable and that way
halfway through the season and the day
before half of his secondary when at
least some like 20,000 pounds that was
pre night out in London yes that was the
the 20,000 pounds led to the two-ton
gorilla yes that that that was part of
the whole Jaguar season all right let's
get into you're gonna be part of the
third day of the draft yeah on the end
of film that works Mimi you DJ and
Charles Davis out there for four day
number three day number night one okay
do you know a single person at all in
the NFL who thinks calamari is not going
number one overall to the Arizona
Cardinals I do not I had one person at
the league meetings who is not a NFL
employee but is pretty connected in
things okay
pulled me aside and said you've been
putting all your eggs in this Kyler
Marie to Arizona basket I'd hold off and
this guy knows things and then I asked
around they're like no he's wrong no
he's going to number one so someone has
been saying what was hold on
why was what was the hold off theory did
you the hold off theory being that there
might be some mega trade to get up to
number one
to Arizona and another team being in the
works we have a former colleague who has
three first-round picks for 24th and
27th and he's the general manager that's
the only team I could imagine that would
have the draft capital to even have the
Cardinals to consider it but from
everything I've heard everyone I've
spoken to Kingsbury is in love with
Kyler Murray and there's a real
relationship
so I mean well the relationship is what
that he he recruited him tried to get
him to Texas Tech they share an agent I
mean he was a sophomore in high school
Kingsbury was recruiting him as if he
was the next Joe Montana then again when
he's transferring from Texas A&M
Kingsbury went again and recruit him
very close friends with the father Kevin
Murray who's Kyler's dad and it's this
quarterback guru Kingsbury is known
Murray for close to eight years you put
that all in process here as far as high
school college and now he's an
opportunity to take the job and takes
the number one pick maybe for a reason
maybe was because he thought Kyler
Murray might be available to be his
quarterback ah so now we assume that's
happening that's the foregone conclusion
despite the guy won guys things who's
not a colleague i connect a guy in the
not a coach or GM or League employee so
hmm
think about the other
world that we work in had a lot of time
when you have sources sometimes they
come from the team side the other time
they come from the agent side so
prominent NFL agent who I never will
their lips were moving so I mean it's
it's it was Marge very moving I put this
one in my head and just it is it played
tricks with me because I've been all-in
on hey Murray's number one let's talk
about number two but that's the only
human being you've come or I have come I
have not come across a single human
being since we left the combine that's
hard to me hold your horses not a single
one I've seen not a single you'll be
lying if I said I have also and there
has not been a single person a team
employee anywhere around the league who
I said anything but Murray to the
colonel and the second part being
alright let's talk about where rosin
goes that's where the conversation and
that as I wrote in my mock draft that's
up at nfl.com I don't know that answer
and I don't know where that's going to
go and whether it's gonna happen day one
when you guys are just getting up there
and it's you know Thursday night April
25th on NFL Network it's got to if it
happens well we if it happens the thing
cuz we've had this conversation before
on the show and I'm glad that you're
here to have it now Peter Schrager of
good morning football here in the Rich
Eisen show from New York City is that
it's got to happen the night of the
draft it's got to happen then out of the
draft it cannot happen say the same way
that the Eagles moved up to number two
and we're all wondering they're coming
up for when sore golf or they're cool
with whatever the Rams take first and
it's not the same as getting up there
and it's either you know knowing that
you're trading for rg3 they're famed
Washington giving less need the entirety
of his future earnings right it's not
the same thing because there was luck in
front this is not the same thing because
Arizona needs to know when they make
this tray absolutely right that Kyler
Mari is healthy is walking the planet
with two good legs with two good arms at
work I'm a sir and doesn't get cold and
doesn't a week before the draft so yeah
baseball's my love well that would be by
the way oh that's what I'm saying that
would make the AAF look like like a
miniseries like like a one-act play dude
if you're Arizona you need to take every
Wolper oceans
so they have to know that when they push
the rosin trade button Murray is there
for the taking he's an you literally
when roger goodell
puts the Cardinals on the clock in
Nashville on the last Thursday of this
month they have to place a phone call to
Kyler Murray and Steve crime and Michael
Bidwell and Kliff Kingsbury have to hear
his voice they probably want to FaceTime
him they want to see him and the voice
come out of his mouth and say take a
nice wide shot of you Kyler do a jumping
jack Kyler can't confirm that he'll be
at the draft but it would be really
reassuring if you're the Cardinals if he
is you see him in the human flesh he's
on TV he's in a suit he's going to the
NFL and he's healthy and he's good and
if he starts saying maybe I'm gonna be
at home like Denny's circuit wishy-washy
I want to know you're all in and you're
healthy and you're gonna for we treat
Josh because then it's I mean you need
to have that in your back pocket well
the time is gonna have it in his top
right drawer top left drawer ready to
pull out once they choose Carla Murray
and then the trade will be announced as
to where Josh Rosen goes because they
need those draft picks that night Friday
night they need to get that thing done
on the spot and right now even if
another team comes out right now and
says I'll give you my one they can't
they can't take it right now agree it
because that would leave them with no
quarterbacks if Carla Murray decides to
just say I'm not coming abso want to
come or whatever thing that's on the
number of times Peter Schreyer good
morning football here on the show the
number of times again that we've gone
through this process
covering the draft that we would hear
again this is my 15th draft I'm doing
for the NFL Network Costas 15 and the
number of times that we would get grief
for showing a player on the phone
because that tips the pit yeah sure the
play you know the player is about to go
so Roger Goodell is like we're not going
to show the players on the phone and
people are gonna be like well why don't
you show players on the phone I want to
see it we'd give us a phone we want
phone I want for the answer is anything
and then the question comes why must
coaches call the player to say we're
taking you why must they do that why is
that necessary and the answer I get back
from every talent evaluator and coach
and owner or general manager in this
league is we need to know they're alive
and they're not joking
yeah like literally like a pagoda on
Letterman come out fog up a mirror but
sound insane but you have to it's for
real you have to know the player that
you are drafting is a functioning human
being on the planet it's the same person
you wanted and I don't want to go down a
negative road here but last year the
Josh Allen thing happens the morning of
the draft Laramie tons those things
happen like things happen at the draft
so calimary everything we know is all
buttoned up it's great but you never
want to train without a back-up plan
because when you mention trading up for
Andrew or trading up for Jared Goff well
if Goff something crazy happened we'll
take once if we trade up to get Robert
Griffin okay well something else happens
there's you know all these other
quarterbacks in this draft
they are trade if they are taking that
first pick it is Kyler Murray they are
not taking Haskins or Locke right it is
all in on Murray so it has to be that
guy and there is no real backup plan
that's why you keep Rosen until then so
what are you hearing about the Rosen
market I mean our colleague Joe Klat
from Fox
Jonah Baba I know and he's gonna be on
night 2 of the NFL Network draft
coverage from Nashville
he said chargers Patriots Giants or name
names and Joel people say well he's not
an NFL insider Joel called just about
every one of Josh Rosen's big games in
the pac-12 for Fox he called all of
Cuyler Murray's big games for the big 12
for Fox Joel has sources too so when he
said that I followed up with him he said
look it happened whatever I sit reported
some of those calls may have just been
inquiries and they might have happened
before free agency which leads me to the
to the Chargers they signed Tyrod Taylor
does that mean they're you know come on
I mean Baker Mayfield is the two words
you need to hear about him in terms of
where you might go and that's why I said
you know when when we heard after cloud
I'm like Porter ah Taylor I mean there
was it it is Rodney aradhna Porter ah
Taylor I mean now he could possibly get
Rosen in in Los Angeles but it makes
sense it makes sense that he's a local
kid yeah it certainly makes sense here
in New York City it makes sense
obviously New England at some point is
going to have to get that next Garoppolo
right yes and and obviously Rosen would
be a perfect opportunity to do something
like that and all of those teams have
interesting things
can offer so the Giants might be
desperate for a quarterback and you
could say six or 17 they have an early
second-round pick the Patriots had the
last pick of the first round the
charters have the 28th pick that seems
to be about the market somewhere in that
twenty to thirty eight range as far as
overall picks for what Josh Rosen's you
already have him one year into the NFL
and the key thing with rosin which has
been mentioned a few times
the Cardinals paid him so much
guaranteed money up front he's making
about an average of three million a year
for the next three years so that you
think about Russell Wilson is gonna be
asking you think about what something
three million years for a potential
starting quarterback is a bargain and
from everyone I talked to in Arizona
right down to Steve Wilkes who I spoke
with at the end of the season and also
at the combine not a bad word to say
about Josh Rosen all those things before
the draft about him possibly being a
petulant kid know he was a mature
professional we all we all buy into that
we were all we were all on the rosin
train last year at the draft so if the
Giants flipped their second-round choice
at the top of Friday night for rosin and
choose two defensive studs in the first
round and then come back to New York can
get them and basically say how do you
like you know think about it I mean
jibril Peppers well I think is a very
good future and I think when I spoke
with gentlemen at the NFL League
meetings he was super high on Jabril you
get two defensive studs so you end up
with Edie Oliver and one of the Clemson
kids off the edge and you get Golden
Tate and you're all right what about you
in your mock draft had Oliver going
forth to the Raiders I'm really high on
Oliver I don't think he gets out of the
top five I really this guy I think the
Jets might even take him this guy is the
one that no one's talking about rich me
besides you and I thought people talked
Aaron Donald is the name that you
mentioned with him that's mentioned with
Quinn and Williams might go before him
because he's this great kid but Quinn
and Williams
comes from a body size that is endowment
consider old McCoy Edie Oliver is a
clone of Aaron Donald's body I'm not
saying he's Aaron Thomas but if you want
to talk about the next wave and how
everyone's like for the next Tyreke
Illit receiver they looking for the next
Aaron Donald it's not Quinn and Williams
it's at Oliver so if the Giants don't
pull the trade for Rosen in your mock
draft you have them drew Locke gave the
wrong name and Daniel Jones before from
Duke drew Locke before Dewayne Haskins
what gives you that idea
there are a few people that I talk to in
the league that do quarterbacks that I
trust who like know and a lot of them
are saying lock over Haskins on some
boards and that might drive Ohio State
fans crazy
I might be wrong when it's all said
knows all takes is one team but locked
quietly had a really good senior Bowl
had an okay combine but was awesome in
the meetings with teams and then blew
everyone away at his pro day Haskins has
done well but he hasn't stolen that hey
I'm the number two hands down guy lock
started for three and a half years
played four years at Missouri has seen
all sorts of offenses and if you look at
what the Giants have drafted
historically it's sure things Dave
gentlemen doesn't like to roll on
another thing that he's not sure this
guy has a body of work has the body type
and I think Locke might actually fit the
Giants more than Haskins who started one
year in college and is still bit of a
prospect Wow I mean if they come up come
back with a quarterback that might not
be on the top three of many people's
mock draft boards again you just put
fans here read and fans talk about but I
don't know I mean this is also a fan
base that went nuts when porzingis got
drafted here in this town and obviously
we saw how that all worked out let's
talk a few more minutes left here with
Peter Schrager good morning football
also Fox as well what are you hearing
about Russell Wilson I mean April 15th
is a deadline I mean they it this is not
something that that just turned around
and shocked John Schneider this is
something that the organization has been
planning for they knew this day would be
coming and Russell had such a phenomenal
year last year does this get done by
April he was awesome last year and a
year that everyone thought they'd go for
in 12 they go to the playoffs I think
John Schneider has not only known this
is coming for this offseason this has
been several off seasons in the making
they've been saving their money I don't
know if they're ready for some deadline
being leaked to the media though in
April 15th is the first day they go to
voluntary of course you want to have
Russell there but deadlines do spur in
action and if you're asking
you know the Seahawks to get a deal done
in the next two week I'm not sure they
operate that way and training camp is
another thing let's get this done before
then the question is what leverage does
Russell Wilson have is he not going to
show up for voluntaries all right we've
seen that before is he not going to show
up to training camp because that's when
this gets really ugly that's when this
gets really hairy and you want to talk
way out of left field when you have
Jimmy Fallon sprinkling out oh so we
heard rumors you might be interested in
going to the Giants when that was really
not like a national story at all that
doesn't come from out
Jimmy Fallon doesn't breathe so I'm
wondering conspiracy theorist I am
reporter I am who plants that with Jimmy
Fallon out of nowhere it's certainly not
the Seahawks and he's certainly not
clicking pro football talk all day long
yeah so I wonder I wonder how that even
gets to a Jimmy Fallon and Russel
laughed it off and ha ha ha
but that was the first I'd heard of
Russell Wilson Tony you're like why
wrestle and that was one of the four
questions they asked Russell Wilson when
he's on Jimmy Fallon it came out of
nowhere
and as I we all know and I let everyone
know the first hour these are all pre
interview questions or you're brought up
I mean like these things are all like
these are the what would you like I mean
these things are they're not totally
planned I mean there are some
off-the-cuff moments for these things
but huh Jimmy Fallon is he tampered with
Kingsbury in McVeigh Kimmel cost magic
like 250 true cuz he did the whole wink
wink
yeah about Paul George you never end up
going to pay the fine after you didn't
even go yeah yeah ask the poll question
of Peter Schrager here I'm Peter Russell
Wilson has said he wants to be the
highest-paid quarterback in the NFL who
deserves to be the highest-paid club's
dessert the choice Russell Wilson the
man who's making the demand yeah Aaron
Rodgers the man who is highest-paid per
year average Tom Brady the goat drew
brees first-ballot hall-of-famer maybe
Mount Rushmore quarterback or Patrick
mahomes I'm a big Moe Holmes guy and
originally my first thought is to go
with the MVP but Brady has never done it
yet Brady has never been that guy to say
you know what once and for all let me
get mine I think Tom Brady one final
contract breaks the bank and says this
is for all my years of taking a discount
sorry guys I'm getting mine I think Tom
Brady deserves the most what is that
number 38 38 over three years you know
what it should be it should the number
should be the number of the Super Bowl
that he first won for them
Oh 38 the most heart meet Holloway 36 36
duh it was it
thirty-six perfect three more but it
should be a two-year deal 36 and 37 you
did in those Super Bowls
that's the starter and then he should
add an incentive like this incentive
based material for for every other the
amount should be for every other ability
one what's the 53 what's the area code
in Ann Arbor seven three four seven
three four somehow it worked that in
there too there you go it starts with
the first Super Bowl he won 30 I love
that and nothing less and then thirty
seven to your deal back-to-back how do
you like me now hey dong-yi we just did
your work for you you know who makes 36
and 53 million dollars his wife Giselle
no unrelated how about me so speaking of
you where are you headed after this I'm
gonna be hanging out with my son two
years old what's his name Mel mal like
the great Mel Brooks is that what you
named him after Mel back and we liked
the name Mel and noblemen by the way I
mean I mean I mean now about you know
Schrager by the way sounds like somebody
that I'd go to Nate nails with
absolutely and I'm sure he will be going
to Nate now his first trip to LA man
there shraeger is that not a great name
is it runs on the corn just straight Mel
or a short for Melvin Melvin Mel okay so
your two-year-old son Mel yeah and you
will be going one of these daddy and me
type deals I mean it's kokkonen I'm
excited it's awesome I love everyone's
like Oh fatherhood I love it it's
amazing yeah Leon I'd say yeah Dom boo
is saying his first pitch Yankee Stadium
is four o'clock is that right should we
do that no it's a beautiful day here in
New York City it sounds like a lot of
work it's a beautiful why I mean do you
wake up every day I wake up at 4 a.m.
every day dude Eastern 1:00 a.m. your
time you look like you're in great shape
trying I mean you work out in the
afternoon yes if I if I can get to that
yes you imagine 4:00 in the morning did
you do that every day the summer I
worked on a lobster boat we got up at
3:00 and it was brutal the bedroom you
were you're droppin bedrooms in the
water
you're doing you don't even know what
I'm talking about in bedrooms yeah you
never saw the bedroom so what they call
the cage you're putting the one out we
just we just caught a trap what they
call Deadliest Catch that show I like
that show yeah 3 a.m. situation wrong
tell me about it or the lobster goes
Bert or Siskel it's ridiculous
the pride of Emory University the
trigger at peace regs on Twitter check
out good morning football every single
day at 7:00 a.m. Eastern Time and I look
forward to having you can't wait
Nashville's in the awesome the draft
night one are you night one and then
date night two and 93 but good morning
football's every morning from Nashville
so we're excited oh that's cool yeah I'd
be great look forward to that p @ p sh
regs on twitter peter Schrager gonna go
hang out with mill and oh my god in me
class the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience